so there's an actor called dustin
hoffman
and years ago he made this movie which
some of you may have heard of called the
graduate
and there's two key scenes in that movie
the first one is the seduction scene i'm
not going to talk about that tonight
the second scene is where he's taken out
by the old guy to the pool
and as a young college graduate the old
guy basically says
one word just one word
and of course all of you know what that
word is it's plastics
and the only problem with that is it was
completely the wrong advice
now let me tell you why it was so wrong
the word should have been silica
and the reason it should have been
silicon is because the basic patents
for semiconductors had already been made
had already been filed and they were
already building them
so silicon valley was just being built
in 1967 when this movie is released
and the year after the movie is released
intel has found it
so had the graduate heard the right one
word maybe he would have ended up on
stage
oh i don't know maybe with these two
so as you're thinking of that let's see
what bit of advice
we might want to give so that your next
graduate doesn't become a tupperware
salesman
so in 2015 what word of advice would you
give people
when you took a college graduate out by
the pool and you said one word just one
word
i think the answer would be life code so
what is life code life code is the
various ways we have of programming life
so instead of programming computers
we're using things to program viruses or
retroviruses or
proteins or dna or rna or
plants or animals or a whole series of
creatures
and as you're thinking about this
incredible ability to make
life do what you want it to do what it's
programmed to do
what you end up doing is you end up
taking what we've been doing for
thousands of years
which is breeding changing
mixing matching all kinds of life forms
and we accelerate and this is not
something new this humble mustard weed
has been modified so that if you change
it in one way
you get broccoli and if you change it in
a second way you get kale
and if you change it in the third way
you get cauliflower
so when you go to these all natural
organic markets
you're really going to a place that
people have been changing the life coat
of plants for a long time
the difference today to pick a
completely politically neutral term is
we're beginning to practice intelligent
design
and that means that instead of doing
this at random and seeing what happens
over generations
we're inserting specific genes we're
inserting specific proteins and we're
changing life code for very deliberate
purposes
and that allows us to accelerate how
this stuff happens
let me just give you one example
some of you occasionally might think
about sex
and we kind of take it for granted how
we've changed sex
so we think it's perfectly normal and
natural to change it
and what's happened with sex over time
is normally
sex equals baby eventually but
in today's world sex plus pill
equals no baby and and again we think
that's perfectly normal and natural but
that has not been the case for most of
human history
and it's not the case for animals and
what it does is it gives us control so
sex
becomes separate from conception and as
you're thinking of the consequences of
that
then we've been playing with stuff
that's a little bit more advanced like
art
not in the sense of painting and
sculpture but in the sense of
assisted reproductive technologies
right so water assisted reproductive
technologies the system reproductive
technologies for things like in vitro
fertilization
and when you do in vitro fertilization
there's very good reasons to do it
you know sometimes you just can't
conceive otherwise
but when you do that what you're doing
is you're separating sex
conception baby so you're
just taking control over when you have
baby you've separated when the baby and
where the baby's fertilized
so you've separated the baby from the
body
from the act and as you're thinking of
other things that we've been doing
think about twins so you can freeze
sperm you can freeze eggs you can freeze
fertilized eggs and what does that mean
well that's a good thing if you're a
cancer patient you're about to go under
chemotherapy or you're about to go under
radiation so you save these things and
don't irradiate them but if you can save
them you can freeze them and you can
have a surrogate mother
it means that you decouple sex from time
means you can have twins born
oh in 50 years
in 100 years 200 years
right and these are three really
profound changes that are not like
future stuff this is stuff that we take
for granted today
so this life code stuff turns out to be
a superpower
it turns out to be this incredibly
powerful way of changing viruses of
changing plants of changing animals
perhaps even of evolving ourselves
that's something that steve gullins and
i have been thinking about for a while
this has some risks like every powerful
technology like electricity
like an automobile like computers so
stuff
potentially can be misused and that
scares a lot of people
and as you apply these technologies you
can even turn human beings into chimeras
remember the greek myth where you mix
animals well some of these treatments
actually end up changing your blood type
or they'll put male
cells in a female body or vice versa
which sounds absolutely horrible until
you realize the reason you're doing that
is you're substituting bone marrow
during
cancer treatments so by taking somebody
else's bone marrow
you may be changing some fundamental
aspects of yourself but you're also
saving your life
and as you're thinking about the stuff
here's something that happened 20 years
ago
so this is emma ott she's a recent
college
admittee she's studying accounting she
played two varsity sports she graduated
as a valedictorian
and that's not particularly
extraordinary except that she's the
first human being born to three
parents why because she had a deadly
mitochondrial disease
that she might have inherited so when
you swap out a third person's dna
and you put it in there you save the
lives of people
but you also are doing germline
engineering which means
her kids will be if she has kids will be
saved
and we'll go through this and her kids
will be saved and their grandchildren
will be saved and this passes on
that makes people nervous so 20 years
ago the various authorities said why
don't we study this for a lot
and there are risks to doing stuff and
the risk to not to make stuff because
there were a couple of dozen people
saved by this technology
and then we've been thinking about it
for the next 20 years
so as we think about it as we take the
time to say hey
maybe we should have longer studies
maybe we should do this maybe we should
do that
there are consequences to acting and
there are consequences to not acting
like curing deadly diseases which by the
way is
completely unnatural right it is normal
and natural for humans to be felt
by massive epidemics of polio of
smallpox of tuberculosis when we put
vaccines into people
we are putting unnatural things into
their body because we think
the benefit way outweighs the risk
because we've built unnatural plants
unnatural animals
we can feed about seven billion people
we can do things
like create new life forms and as you
create new life forms
again that sounds terribly scary and
terribly bothersome
until you realize those life forms live
on your dining room table
those flowers you've got on your dining
room table there's not a lot that's
natural about them
because people have been breeding the
flowers to make this color to be this
size to last for a week
you don't usually give your loved one
wildflowers because they don't last a
whole lot
a whole lot of time
what all this does is it flips darwin
completely on his head
see for four billion years what lived
and died on this planet depended on two
principles
on natural selection and random mutation
and so what lived and died what was
structured
has now been flipped on its head
and what we've done is we've created
this completely parallel evolutionary
system
where we are practicing unnatural
selection and non-random mutations so
let me explain these things
this is natural selection this is on
natural selection
so what happens with this stuff is we
started breeding wolves
thousands of years ago in central asia
to turn them into dogs and then we start
turning them into big dogs and we start
turning in little little dogs
but if you take one of the chihuahuas
you see in the air maze bags on fifth
avenue
and you let it loose on the african
plain you can watch natural selection
happen
a few things on earth are less natural
than a cornfield
right you will never under any scenario
walk through a virgin forest and see the
same plant growing in orderly rows
at the same time nothing else living
there
when you do a corn field you're
selecting what lives and what dogs
and you're doing that through unnatural
selection and it's the same with the
wheat field it's the same with the rice
field
it's the same with the city it's the
same as a suburb in fact half the
surface of earth
has been unnaturally engineered so that
what lives and what dies there
is what we want which is the reason why
you don't have grizzly bears
walking through downtown manhattan
how about this random mutation stuff
well this is random mutation this is
antonio fonseca
he's otherwise known as the octopuses
his nickname he was a relief pitcher of
the year in 2000
and he had a random mutation that gave
him six fingers on
each hand which turns out to be really
useful if you're a pitcher
how about non-random mutation a
non-random mutation is
beer it's wine it's yogurt
how many times have you walked through
the forest and found all natural cheese
or all natural yogurt right so we've
been engineering this stuff now the
interesting thing is we get to know the
stuff better
we found one of the single most powerful
gene editing
instruments crispr inside yogurt
and as we start engineering cells we're
producing
eight out of the top ten pharmaceutical
products
including the stuff that you use to
treat arthritis which is the number one
best-selling drug humera
so this life coat stuff it really is a
superpower
it really is a way of programming stuff
and there's nothing that's going to
change us
more than this life code so as you're
thinking of life code
let's think of five principles as to how
we start guiding
and i'd love you to give me more so
principle number one
we have to take responsibility for this
stuff and the reason we have to take
responsibility
is because we're in charge these aren't
random mutations
this is what we are doing what we are
choosing it's not stuff happen
it didn't happen at random it didn't
come down by a verdict of somebody else
we engineered this
and it's the pottery barn rule you break
it you own it
principle number two we have to
recognize and celebrate diversity in
this stuff
there have been at least 33 versions of
hominins
that have walked around this earth most
all of them went extinct except us
but the normal and natural state of this
earth is we have various versions of
humans walking around the same time
which is why most of us have some
neanderthal in us
some of us have some venison in us and
some in washington have a lot more of it
principle number three
we have to respect other people's
choices some people will choose
to never alter some people will choose
to alter all some people choose to alter
plants but not animals some people
choose to alter themselves
some people choose to involve themselves
diversity is not a bad thing
because even though we think of humans
as very diverse we came so close to
extinction
that all of us descend from a single
african mother and the consequence of
that is there's more genetic diversity
in 55 african chimpanzees than there are
in seven billion humans
principle number four we should take
about a quarter of the earth
and only let darwin run the shoulder
it doesn't have to be contiguous it
doesn't have to all be tied together
it should be part in the oceans part on
land but we should not run
every evolutionary decision on this
planet we want to have
our evolutionary system running we want
to have darwin's evolutionary system
running
and it's just really important to have
these two things running in parallel
and not overwhelm evolution
the last thing i'll say this is the
single most exciting adventure human
beings have been on this is the single
greatest superpower humans have ever had
it would be a crime for you not to
participate in the stuff because you're
scared of them
because you're hiding from it you can
participate in the ethics you can
participate in the politics you can
participate in the business you can
participate
in just thinking about where medicine is
going and where industry is going and
where we're going to take the world
it would be a crime for all of us not to
be aware
when somebody shows up at a swimming
pool and says one word
just one word if you don't listen if
that word is life cut
thank you very much
you